vous êtes prêts oui bah j'ai pas le
choix de poisson merci d'être là les
séries et merci d'avoir fait touche pas
à mon poste le 1er tokyo tous les soirs
à 19h vous êtes vraiment les amours
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
à la fin
e
[Applaudissements]
jean michel mr alesi allez vous mettre
en place sur le trap moi si tu peux et
on va voir on va voir si vous allez
pouvoir répondre au moins à cinq
questions en 30 secondes
danse et marina qui va jouer marina ça
va être des questions que des questions
base de ce sont les cours d'accor riom
voilà mathématiques littérature etc
si vous répondez mal on fera tomber la
trame des deux côtés et ils ne savent
pas ce qui se passe ils savent pas ce
qu'il y a un visage assez nouvelle
grille ils ne savent pas ce qu'il ya en
dessous la trappe
marina mathématiques combien font lutte
par 8 me farid 64 bien jouer littérature
qui a écrit le journal d'anne frank
un franck anne frank astronomie quelle
est la plus grosse planète du système
solaire jupiter stop on s'arrête là il
ya trois points top top top top jupiter
un jouet marina combien font 1 euros en
francs c'est ce que j'essaie d'apprendre
en ce moment chez à 6,55 data que
désigne le premier chiffre d'autre de
notre cible numéro de sécurité sociale
c'est quoi cette vie passée passex le
quoi oui le sexe et mort à quel genre
d'article appartient à une waits et des
articles des ânons mais ce n'est pas un
article indéfini soit c'est qu'un avis
oui pardon
ouais merci mme amina mais j'ai perdu
quand même puisque en plus isabelle
morini bosc
malheureusement je vais demander aux
autres invités s'ils veulent sauver
quelqu'un oualalou denis et frédéric est
ce qu'on voulait sauver un des deux
nous donnions non il ya certains groupes
de cartes une faune montagnat se voulait
sauver quelque chose sachez quand même
vous êtes prêts oui bah j'ai pas le
choix
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
mais je savais même pas tiré
[Applaudissements]
célibataire c'est vrai marina quel album
fearless est sortie elle est en tournée
non
[Musique]